- So you must love dancing,
man, because we got a video
of you and Patrick Wilson dancing.
So wait, here's the...
There you go.
(audience laughing)
And then watch, and, and, and...
He went straight up 90s, like he went...
- Running man.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Do you love dancing?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] Me too, it feels good.
- We invented the hula.
- Yeah.
Oh, that's true, okay.
Well...
- I like shaking it,
you know what I mean?
- We just invented having
good time in a bar.
That's what Texans did (laughing).
So I heard that you
were jealous of Patrick
'cause he got to eat a ton,
'cause he had to gain weight for the roll.
And you were trying to stay lean.
I heard that you had to
watch him eat a lot of stuff.
- But he had to get slim too.
He looks beautiful in this one.
He got a little grumpy too.
- Oh, he did?
- When you're starve...
Yeah, when you're
starving yourself to like-
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean, you're not getting to eat.
Like now I'm eating pasta
every meal, it feels good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
This is, I'm getting ready for Minecraft,
you know what I mean?
(all laughing)
I gotta let this slip down into here, so.
- It's different, I love it.
- Bulking season.
- I love, oh my God (laughing).
Gotta keep warm for the winter.
Here's a behind-the-scenes look
at Jason training for the movie.
This is actually rad, watch (exclaiming).
I would die.
- [Jason] So this is like that creature
that you just saw me on right here.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's just, we found this in my phone,
but it's just me being...
(audience laughing)
- So what...
What...
(audience lauhging)
What training was that for?
(audience applauding)
- Well, that's how you go faster.
- Okay, okay.
- So if you want the animal to go faster,
you gotta really go.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
I just was curious.
- You have to slow it down
because you have to slow it down.
(audience cheering)
Because there's no steering wheel.
- It's a different kind of
training is all I'm saying.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- No, there was a really awesome
Aquaman suit in this one.
I like this one.
Did you like that transition for daytime?
(all laughing)
Look, I didn't know how to segue, so I...
No, you do.
You have a really cool suit for this one.
I like this one.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Do you feel powerful in that?
- I do.
- I would feel really cool.
You know what's really fun
is you're talking to someone,
you'll be on set with one of the grips,
and then you have to go put the suit on,
and you come back 15 minutes later,
and then you're like,
"Hey, what's up Bob?"
And they're just like-
- They're intimidated.
- Yeah.
'Cause you got the eyes
in and it like the hair
and the body.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you're a lot bigger than
what you were 15 minutes ago.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I'd be scared as (beep) of that guy, yeah.